okay here we go
I think we're live now what's up guys we
are doing some VFX today let's get let's
get this let's get this one little thing
I get boom now we're in now we're in
alright so I really wanted to do this
for you guys wanted to walk through some
cool cinema for the octane stuff last
year's been crazy it's a very fun sweet
okay now it's live yeah let me know guys
let me know how this is going here
because um doubled on audio what about
now
appreciate your heads up here first time
doing this live stream so might be a
little janky you know hot out the gates
but we'll get it right I know we're
right you know I wish I wish I could
hear how I sound right now I can't I
can't hear how I sound so I have no idea
it looks like we got like a 30-second
delay here
still double let's see alright what
about now how is this sounded better
yo yo welcome welcome welcome
trying to get technical side solved here
first time going on this now guys we get
I literally bought I literally bought a
microphone just for this year so we're
gonna make sure we got the audio son and
really nice much better yes yes yes
that's what's up perfect sweet so right
now I am streaming with cinema 4d and
the beautiful little render you see
right here is rendered through octane
however you guys you know I don't know
how many of you guys are trying to get
into the effects or doofy effects
yourself the reason I got into it is
because I realized I could do literally
anything you you want it I can do
anything I want make anything I want if
I know technically how to do it and
that's what I'm kind of spawned my
interest and this whole you know visual
effects world and it can get very
technical I can get very advanced but
once you get past all that and you find
the right tutorials which hopefully this
will be then you'll be off to the races
you can be making really cool stuff now
cinema 4d is I think they just released
a subscription service that's like 60
bucks a month octane is 20 bucks a month
so I know 80 bucks a month is little
could be a little pricey for some of you
guys now blender is completely free
which is amazing and you can do amazing
stuff in blender so you know you guys
want to keep that in mind you could
likely follow along if you guys download
blender if you want to get into CG and
whatnot there's a whole bunch of great
blender tutorials but you know I want to
share my expertise in cinema that can
hopefully be translated to blender or
3ds max or any other programs because
it's all just kind of like building
block foundation and stuff that I want
to start with and I do want to take
requests from you guys to see what you
guys want more of
but let's go through these comments here
what are you guys saying so we fixed the
audio that's good am i coming to
Scotland yes at some point just went to
Ireland last year it was amazing
mmm what's software am i streaming on
I'm UV I'm using OBS right now literally
first time doing this
you like Obi Obi Wan Kenobi likes
watching editing videos cuz it makes you
feel like you can do it totally I know
exactly what you mean Christian dude
what's up Christian
yeah everyone say hey Christian
Christian from corridor thanks for
stopping by dude let's see eight years
ago I started doing them cuz Freddie
Wong and you guys but I kind of lost
interest but I have it but I've been
watching VFX stuff recently and loved it
I tried cinema once and my computer
almost exploded blender good luck
finding a job good luck using blender in
larger productions it falls apart fast
well man man it might it might I don't
know I've never used it but I do know
Ian Hubert is like a blender master and
same for Peter France he did the the
spider-man short on corridor and it's
those guys are geniuses when it comes to
blender so if you're if you have any
reason like I don't know about blender
go take a look at those guys or blender
guru three amazing people with blender
and they will prove to you that blender
is the greatest let's see let's see what
happened to me a rocket jump oh that's a
that's a question that's a personal
question so Freddie Freddie's doing his
own thing right now he is doing a
podcast dungeons and daddies and they're
looking to write a lot of like feature
films and try and do some bigger stuff
so right now it's just Freddie Freddie
and Matt I believe let's see you guys
the reason I'm doing VFX now started as
a fan and I'm now I'm lucky enough to do
them as my
job that is awesome that makes me feel
very very good red beats 13 sweet man
yeah it's super fun it's very fun you
can create anything it's the best what
am I making
so we can make a few things today I was
thinking we could go through how to make
well here let's let's let's jump in here
so I love making textures and when I'm
you know walking about during the day I
and yes you know it might be a little
knowing here but like I'll just kind of
walk really slowly and look at textures
and get mesmerized by certain textures
and be like oh I want to make this I
want to make that so the other day let's
see if I can pull the picture for you
guys don't it here we go
my octane textures my assets let's see
where is it we're gonna save these I'm
trying to find the reference photos for
you guys here mmm wait
sure we'll start we will start with give
me sec let me put the photo so the this
this right here the what you're seeing
is like a dirty rainy kind of vibe here
and the rain is like pulling up in the
corners it's darker in the corners and
it's based off of my dirty car because
in Los Angeles it you know we work next
to the freeway it is very dirty it rains
diesel dust basically all day 24/7 and
it rains rarely right so when it does
rain it kind of washes all that stuff
off and it ends up looking a little
something like this really nasty and I
thought hey you know that'd be really
fun to do do a texture on because these
days you can basically download any
texture you want
there's a million brick textures a
million rock textures a million
there's a million textures everywhere
and what I'm trying to do when I go out
I'm trying to find textures that are
unique like this one here and I enjoy
creating them so I'd like to show you
guys that that's an option we have other
textures we got let me let me show you
the reference first before I get
distracted that is the tiniest picture
in the world okay
come on computer
where are you at where you at where the
pictures there D on the desktop I don't
know where they are
all right here we go so you can see the
dirt you know is all up in here and it's
collected on the edges another example
this one right here you know you can see
how the dirt kind of just like it
catches the rain and it gets pushed down
by the rain and it just stays there and
then it sticks there so that was the
reference for for this texture here so
we can break that down let me open up
another one for you guys um let's see we
got a cast iron texture so recently for
Christmas my girlfriend got me a really
nice cast iron like Japanese teapot and
it's a kind of teapot that it holds you
know iron and when you heat up hot water
when you boil water and this thing you
get these patterns like this like these
little like dried up pieces of water
that pulls the iron out of the cast iron
and it's supposedly really good for you
to have in your tea actually got some
right here and I wanted to figure out a
way to you know to create that texture
because it's something I've never seen
before
so we can do that or finally this might
be more of a general general thing for
you guys more interest to you guys
I'll check the comments here in a second
but let's see if we can't recreate a
scene from one of our favorite movies
let's see let's see where would it be
spirited away now if you guys have seen
spirited away
you know it's pretty crazy movie and it
is it has some really amazing art in it
as well so you know you got some classic
stuff in this movie we can we can go in
and create any number of scenes from
this movie this would be a fun one this
would be super fun and this is just kind
of like a collection of pictures where
I'll go through a movie that I really
like and I'll save out screenshots for
reference or for inspiration but this
one this is the one I kind of wanted to
I was feeling I like this vibe here it's
very foggy it's rainy time aspheric this
one too it would be fun
these will all be fun to recreate this
one this would be a good one actually
it's pretty pretty basic but we can
learn a lot on how to get this look
let's see what do you guys think let's
go through these comments um alright
let's see let's see best place to learn
cinema 4d v effects well I should say
right here but the sense this is my
first one might be a little janky I
learned through greyscale gorilla
greyscale gorilla they're the best man
their tutorials are amazing they're free
they do have a paid subscription service
that you can uh you can subscribe to but
I learned a lot through greyscale
gorilla I learned a lot through David
Mann I get that his last name mixed up
all the time David are you David re EV
it's like on his website and he was like
two WS or like two V two V's that make a
WI it it's difficult anyway um I design
is another good one these guys are
incredible they put out the best
tutorials let's see let's see what you
guys are saying dabbling in V effects
but might come back hopefully we can get
you back
glad you're talking about textures some
have been very curious about I often
want to retexture a file I've downloaded
but aren't sure how to make these more
realistic that is exactly what I do all
the time i download models from
turbosquid the textures are always but
and you got to go in and you got to
retexture the whole thing so this whole
process I was talking about is exactly
that you make cool cool textures there's
a lot of like little tips and tricks
that you can use to quickly retexture
something you can save your textures out
you can if you have to start from
scratch there's a there's a number of
like easy ways you can go about it to
make something look awesome pretty
quickly um let's see how is a 10-7 TTI
going to perform and c4d well i have a
gtx 1070 so great I have one gtx 1070 my
voice is looping hopefully that is just
you yet know looking at my own awesome
car warfare 3 eventually yes it will
happen
sci-fi stay tuned at some point
alright any preference as to what we're
gonna do here what car is that is FRS
and start from bottom because you got a
lot of comments Thanks um build
something in Minecraft which I make who
knows me and that's up that's up to you
that's that's personal the golden tower
in Japan you know what guys let's see
first scene with the rain back bathhouse
has iconic would be more work but I'd be
cool um all right let's do this one guys
let's just do this one cuz this will be
fun it'll be pretty easy too so let us
just start a new scene here and I'll
check these comments periodically from
time to time make sure that we're all
good alright sweet ok so we have a very
unique silhouette here that is the
bathhouse now since you know since this
is mostly just a silhouette right it's
not super detailed we don't need to go
to the max on this we just need to get
the silhouette right so we could
certainly do like the speed version of
this and trace the silhouette of it so
you know let's just model it out yeah
let's just model it out really quick all
right so let's jump in
so for reference let's let's just make a
new material just going to double click
down here go in here and we're going to
drag and drop that picture that
reference picture into the color tab
said no always had no on that stuff we
want to make a background and if you
ever need to find something at c40 just
hit shift C and type what you want and
there's your background or you could you
know eventually as you use the program
find out exactly where it is you know
it's right there under this little floor
tab if you hold it down go to background
so we have a background but you don't
see anything got to drag that picture
boom on to the background but we still
don't see anything that's because our
octane sky is blocking it let's get rid
of let's get rid of this this scene here
so we got our bath house chillin chillin
in the background here and here's our
little grid so we want to get that shape
right we want to get that shape we
probably want to start with a cube
that'd be what I'd do so it's looking
more like a little rectangle so probably
something like this and it's kind of
looks like you have this piece here and
then you got your your Pizza Hut roof
here so I'll make this cube editable hit
C or you could just click this button up
here make editable and no matter what
program you guys are in you're gonna
want to learn those shortcuts because
they will save you time lots and lots
and lots of time there are new shortcuts
so you can get fast so let's let's start
shaping this thing out
okay Pizza Hut roof probably to come up
a little bit like this and then it looks
like it's gonna be a bevel boom and
that's a little a little too high so
we'll bring that down and if I'm going
too fast just let me know if you want me
to like let you guys know the exact
shortcuts I'm using again this is the
first the first stream guys so they will
well get we'll get there we'll get there
in time I want to do I want to do these
once a week but I think you guys get the
idea right I'm kind of just shaping this
out you know then we have some
primitives up here we got like a little
cone we have some cylinders so let's
save that detail roof stuff for last all
right
what else here we got some stuff on the
side like some trees and whatnot it
looks like there's some trees there we
got trees over here there's a bridge
it looks like the bath house has like a
little entrance piece so let's do the
entrance piece real quick so we want to
make like a line cut through this so you
can hit KL u @k it'll bring up your
options of what to do what to do from
there and if you leave the mouse still
you can see you know we can do a plane
cut by hitting J a line cut by hitting K
or a loop path cut by hitting L so KL is
the move here won't look like that we
will grab this little piece here and
extrude it out to get this little look
right here boom and the base it's like
standing on a base of some sort so we
want to you see how it comes in out and
down right here so we can do that by
let's see we want to bevel that and see
what our options are for the bevel here
on top right
did I save the scene always save your
scene will get the lighting right in a
second here um so subdivisions it's go
like five subdivisions you see how it's
kind of bowing out we want it to bow in
so I would say that would be convex
let's see how would we do that it's
fixed distance radial proportional
polygon extrusion zero way you oh here
we go check this out just figure this
out just now alright so the shape of
this bevel let's switch it to user and
it looks like we can just shape it
ourselves here with these little points
so we want it to start to be something
like let's get rid of that let's get rid
of that let's take this guy down like
that alright so that obviously looks
horrible so if we don't want to do that
it's like it's working - this little
middle piece what does that middle piece
doing
okay that's a little closer that's
basically it you know - that last it's
kind of looking a little funky right
there
but for the sake of this tutorial that
shape is looking like that shape
so let us let's try one last thing
and I just ruined it totally discerned
it
let's see we want to get those those uh
Bezier curves back but how do we do that
you know there it is totally works let's
go from there
extrude that guy down and it's actually
when I bring up the what is this one
about what about in here mmm and then
I've hidden W so that would be extrude
inner which basically takes something
and just scales it in like this so we
want to take this piece at the bottom
and scale it up so we're basically
meeting the edge of the bath house and
then we will extrude it back down like
that so you got your little lip right
there
boom alright let's let's go to these
comments here what do you guys what are
you guys talking about these are also
random questions do I like dogs yes dogs
are cool I just got a new cat though so
more of a cat guy right now tips were
getting started on VFX um let's see well
I'd say really honestly like blender is
amazing because it's free you're able to
get into it because it's free when you
know that you want to do something like
you want to have a reason for why you're
doing something so if you can follow a
tutorial or if it's honestly if it's
difficult for you to follow the tutorial
just randomly like if you find that
boring if you're on the airplane and you
know you kind of want to get into V
effects but you have time you're in the
car or you're in an airplane download
some tutorials for a program that you've
heard of that you think would be cool
type of V effects tutorials whatever if
you don't know the program but try and
just familiar it familiarize yourself
with the programs that are out there
that can do the cool stuff you want to
get into the reason I mentioned blender
is just because it's free and there's a
lot of great tutorials for it out there
and just take time and follow these
tutorials and like figure out what you
can do with the program because it's
like you know you give something to
someone and they're like well why do I
want this why do I need this you need to
figure out why you need it why you want
it so finding a reason for why you're
doing that the visual effect would help
certainly like if you have a job that
you know you have to do X Y or Z so
there's your reason you got to figure it
out because if a job or you know you
have an idea that you think is really
cool and you have like you and your
friends get together and like all guys
we should do this that's a reason right
they're just out of pure hobby maybe
you're just getting started you're just
like you're in high school or something
and you need you need some extra cash
well you'd grow your value you would
learn how to do something in a program
like this
and take on freelance jobs that's that's
the first very first job that I got were
freelance jobs with After Effects and
then cinema4d
was the next one but there's a whole
bunch more stuff you know there's a
whole lot more stuff just learn as much
as you can and make it fun for yourself
make it fun and if you can learn if you
can just just break the barrier of like
I don't know what I'm doing - I kind of
get this it might take it will take
consistency and some dedication to the
program and just some some of your time
you can really dive in and have a whole
bunch of fun doing this stuff it's the
best you can you know it's like painting
it's like it's like drawing but you're
doing it in in in 3d so much fun um yes
I miss being on fire it's a little cold
right now
Lowen PCB effects stuff let's see mm-hmm
honestly I don't have that much info on
on PC recommendations I've had friends
help me build a computer a couple times
and it's pretty cheap pretty
cost-effective but honestly fine find a
friend who's good at computers and just
ask him to put together like a gaming
rig for you and chances are that gaming
rig will work perfect for VFX
let's see let's see what you do with
your hair I didn't cut it that's what I
did with my hair
I've been too busy let's see do I still
contact Carmichael for VFX not for VFX
but I still contact Carmichael that's
for sure he's a good dude
I really just really appreciate you guys
uh stopping by for the stream here I
there's a lot to catch up on so last
year right around Thanksgiving time I
came out with a website if you guys
never seen the website this is it so I
do photography is one of my many hobbies
and I over the over the years I have put
together a portfolio of all my travel
photography my friend Jan got me into
film photography so I started messing
around with film you know this is
actually this is jann right here this is
Jan right here as well and I was like
you know what I think it's time to make
a website for my photography because
there's a lot of it at this point and
I've been to enough places that like I
have a decent body of work and it's
something that once I make this website
I will have forever and all of my you
know travel experiences or street
photography it'll be a place for all
that stuff to live so yeah check this
out so if you go to collections you can
see the photos from Japan or Ireland and
you know these these are this island is
all film photography Shanghai's digital
Los Angeles is a mix California coasts
film Newfoundland is film Bali is
digital but you know it's it's
is actually really sweet let me show you
the Japan stuff this guy man I love this
picture so much it was a in Akihabara
which is basically like a place in Tokyo
where you go to get parts for any
electronic it's a very like nerdy kind
of a electric kind of vibe you know
there's people are selling parts
batteries conductors look at like look
at all this stuff I didn't know what
half this stuff is but it was just this
little guy and this booth and I was like
oh man I gotta get that shot and it took
me like 10 minutes to do it because I
was too nervous to be like hey can I
take a shot of you so I just snuck it
and I'm glad I did because I like I like
the way it looks versus him like looking
at the camera and smiling or looking at
the camera doing whatever I think it's
cool but man I love Japan so much it's
like the best place ever this day was
incredible in Takayama
my friend Jung we just like biked around
this place so beautiful there's a
morning market the river behind her and
everything biking along the river got
some nice like industrial vibes but yeah
if you guys if you guys like him you
this stuff one of the reasons I did this
was to sell some prints so you know I
have Newfoundland prints for sale Japan
pictures for sale Ireland pictures for
sale like this one right here they're
all printed on super high quality
archival print paper and it's lil give
you guys an idea of like what it looks
like to have it framed and this was
actually rendered in c40 as well and
yeah like sign them all and ship them
out with incense and and you know a
whole bunch of different sizes and
everything so yeah if you guys are you
guys looking for a way to support me in
the meantime this is a good way to do so
and I hope to post more pictures in the
meantime
and one of my goals this year is to
release a digital product for you guys I
don't know what that is yet
could be texture stuff could be tutorial
stuff who knows but in the meantime
let's just get back to this tutorial so
we got our shape kind of let's get this
bridge going this little guy right here
so this shouldn't be too difficult um
what's cool about I guess the effects in
general just like with life there are
different ways about doing things you
can go about something in 3 or 4
different ways so let's make this bridge
I'll show you a couple different ways so
basically bridge is probably looking
something like that and why is it so
thick because I'm going to take out this
little piece right here with a cylinder
and it's called a boolean I don't know
why it sounds weird but that's just what
it's called so you can kind of get the
idea what I'm going for here scale this
guy up squish it down a little bit and
we're gonna take out that chunk right
there that looks about right so this is
a technically what what are these called
they're not effectors they're like
there's well they are things to
manipulate your model and help you
create some crazy stuff that you don't
normally get from primitives and
perimeters are like your square your
your sphere your cylinder your cone and
whatnot so we made a bull object and
basically it works like a like an order
system so basically you have you have
your bridge which is your cube so a
minus B equals C
and there's your bridge another way of
doing that another way of getting your
bridge would be to do something like
this where you have your cube and it
probably scale it down like that and
we're gonna want to subdivide this thing
this way a whole bunch and if you make
that editable you should be able to take
the ends of this thing let's drag this
out
you should be able to take the ends of
this thing and this might be a little
janky this is probably the janky way of
doing this and you're gonna want to move
them down and I think you guys can kind
of get what I'm going for and this is
probably the longer manual way of doing
this you can go over here and with the
move tool selected you can do what's
called a soft selection and if you
enable that you can see ok the stuff in
yellow is really going to move but the
stuff that's more on the blue side he's
not going to move and the reason it's
not looking like a bridge or now is
because it's set to linear if we set
that to like dome or something
we can bring the radius back let's do I
don't let's keep it at 100 to bring the
strength down to like 30 okay so that's
the opposite of what we want we want
more of a bell curve like that and we're
gonna have to get the top of the bridge
back to a normal flat walkway so one way
of doing that you can turn off the
selection tool you can grab all of these
pieces across the top you can bring them
up for now and then we're going to scale
them down
until this number here the y-axis is
zero and you bring it back down that's
another way being the bridge but you
guys saw this is faster way faster so I
like fast that's good all right we got a
bridge we got our silhouette roughly let
us curve this roof a little bit I'm
seeing here on the corner this roof
curves down and this is looking a little
to Pizza Hut for me so let's let's do
that how we can do that well we could do
it the manual way like we did before and
I'm actually thinking that might be the
best way about going about this we can
make some cuts right so in theory this
is what we're gonna do we're gonna make
that cut there and we're going to we're
gonna scale it down right that's like
the low poly version if we did if we
made some more cuts right there right
there I'm holding shift so like snap
them two angles you can start to let's
get let's do the scale scale tool and
enable the soft selection again let's
bring the radius down to 20 and let's
scale that let's see let's scale it down
and just we got to work our our settings
here to get the right settings so you
can kind of see that working but we
don't want to scale that so we'll bring
our strength back and it's still doing
it it's still like bringing that in
there so I think what I'll do is just do
the manual version of this without the
soft selection let's move it down
and then let's take the other two rings
and bring them down then you can see we
have a curved roof here we did it
manually and that's okay sometimes you
got to do it manually go back for the
middle one scale it down a little bit
more cool looking good and lastly the
the last like main thing three things
actually so you have these little spires
we'll do those real quick we have some
trees here and we have some trees and
some like mountainous stuff here let's
do the spires first so right off the bat
I'm seeing a little cone there that's
gonna be the easiest thing in the world
because it is a primitive will spawn a
cone bring it up it looks like it could
be circular it could be more polygamy so
instead of 36 rotational segments we do
for rotational segments let's just do
that save on some polygons here because
at the end of the day that's one of the
things chomping away your RAM chopping
away at your computer juice bring this
guy down and oh here's a good tip this
this is a tip that mm-hm drove me crazy
for the longest time so we have the cone
connected to the roof right here right
we want to scale it down but it's not
scaling from the bottom it's only
scaling from the middle because the
little gizmo is in the middle we want to
bring the gizmo down to the bottom how
do you do that well first you got to
make it editable you can't do anything
until you make it editable as far as I
know there might be another way to do it
so you can hit C on your keyboard or you
can hit this button over to the top left
I'll hit C because remember those
remember those those shortcuts they will
save you time
you're not seeing your gizmo because
you're on the line mode we want to go to
object mode up here there you go so now
we're dealing with this with this guy
we want this gizmo to be down at the
bottom a couple ways of doing this you
know just like in life there's a whole
bunch of different ways about going
about things let's see so I'm hitting
I'm hitting s on the keyboard to snap my
view to the object I have selected so
hit s boom brings me a write up to this
keep this cone here this tool right here
enable access and if you hover over
stuff it'll it'll show you the shortcuts
so I'm seeing L boom I'm gonna hit L now
instead of moving the object it's gonna
move the axis sweet so we can manually
move it down to the bottom like that hit
L again to get back to object mode and
now when we scale it it scales from the
bottom but instead of eyeballing it if
you really need to get it exact a new
tip I learned from let's see it was a DM
a la it was a cool it was a cool little
thing that we actually spoke at for our
Boston Dynamics video but before that
one of the cinema4d guys talked about
this little tip and it is this tool
right here the axis Center tool now who
knows where that is in cinema it's not
gonna be there I promise because that is
a custom little button I put right there
it might be under tools it might be
under select but you know what the easy
way to find it
axis Center tool is to hit shift C and
type in axis Center and there it is and
if you want to keep that as like a
button that you're always going to use I
use it all the time you can click and
drag it right up into there and it will
stick up into your little toolbar and if
you want to keep it there and have it be
there every time you load cinema you
want to go to window customization save
startup layout boom and cinema will
always open in the configuration you
have setup so let's select the cone
let's select the axis Center tool
his little window and in this window you
can do a number of things you can you
have you're controlling the axis right
so we want the y-axis because we know up
and down is y-axis and it's the nerdiest
thing but the way I remember that is
like when you go up and down it's you're
like yeah and it goes up air goes down
because that's what you say when you go
up or down right we slide that guy down
to negative 100 and he executes and it
snaps perfectly to the bottom of that
cone so there you go bring it down and
we scale it I think now we're at the
point we're like we need to start
setting up our camera and obviously this
is not exact the shape of this is not
exact but you know it's close enough
right
we're trying to get the the essence of
this bath house right so let's it looks
like it's on the far left corner so you
can grab that little piece here and
that'll slide it around on the floor you
know that would be Z and X axis and
let's let's make a camera so technically
we already have one but let's start
locking it into place here what do you
guys think focal length on this you're
probably on a mountain looking at this
thing
maybe it's a 50 let's say it's a it's a
50 could be an 85 could be a 35 but yeah
let's go with 54 now because it looks
like the picture is taken from quite a
ways away and that's pretty close that
is pretty darn close
zoom in a little bit cool
so that cone right here is super tiny so
we'll bring will scale that guy down and
just kind of move it to the edge boom
and this little toggle here the white
like crosshair box thing that's to get
you in and out of the camera and so many
times I will have set my camera like
this and then I'll like start going in
and you know start moving around and
like oh crap
I had my camera set up well if you hit
control shift Z that undoes camera moves
so all good control shift Y redoes
camera moves but just make sure you're
getting at getting out of your camera
toggling in and out of your camera cuz
now we're gonna go in and we're gonna
start doing some more stuff so this
little bell tower let's do that it's
looking like a cylinder to me but before
I do that let's just jump in here and
see if you guys are still alive where
you at where you at where is my stream
alright what's up guys
sweet sweet what's this countdown for
y'all countdown 51 50 53 what's going
down
Boston Dynamics loving the photography
thanks guys um yeah you guys forgot I
had a channel I know I hadn't posted
this thing in so long it's been a very
long time and I'm really excited to do
this more often I love like I will
literally just come home and texture for
fun so why not share the information see
you guys and I hope next time I do this
maybe it'll be Saturday maybe Sunday
we'll get on a schedule so that you guys
can start counting on these things you
guys can be following along in cinema or
if you have blender we can open that up
and we can figure it out together I'll
be in cinema you'll be in blender and
we'll be doing some texture and stuff
for model and stuff and we'll just this
could be our time to spend together to
like to learn
and focus on 3d stuff I think that could
be really cool
sweet yeah glad you guys are enjoying
this and in the future you know hope to
have some like cool music going on here
maybe some ambient music some peaceful
music do you guys have any questions any
requests any any questions whatsoever we
can do like work questions life
questions hobby questions or if you have
questions on specific things you would
like for me to discuss so we can do
After Effects stuff we can do cinema 4d
stuff we can learn substance to designer
together substance designer is crazy
it's like you can make any texture from
noise maps which are just black and
white maps that you push and pull
geometry with I've always wanted to get
into that we can learn that together
yeah ask away guys ask away I'm gonna be
doing this little spire well you guys
asked some questions
so if you want to spawn a if you guys
want to spawn a an object on another
object you select your object right like
this cone hold down control and let go
boom it's spawned on there because I
know I want it to be on the roof so
might as well spawn it next to something
that's on the roof it's like right there
right yeah
that's that's fine let's uh make that
editable editable that's a hard word to
say let's do our little trick here bring
the axis down at the bottom so we have
control more control over this thing
because the end of the day you just
trying to get control over your pixels
right want to push and pull those things
so it's doing some funky like chess
piece business right looks like a little
pawn piece so I'm a scale this down to
the size of this tiny little the
smallest part of this tower and then I'm
going to push out the geometry for the
remainder of the stuff so let's move
this guy up and from what guys for
whatever reason with cylinders watch
this watch this
you come in here you do your loop
selection right you want to scale it up
you want to extrude it just kidding you
want to extrude inner and it's working
it's working properly
sweet never mind let's keep going with
this thing we scale it out we extrude it
oh my goodness we extrude it up and then
we get a little bell action on this guy
let's some extrude it up to the top so
on you see I'm here I'm on this little
lip I'm an extruder inner again right
because it comes in I'm looking at this
piece right here you gotta get that Eli
boom boom boom and then scale it way up
and we can push and pull these polygons
further once we get the general shape
right we can make it thicker shorter
whatever and let's do let's see how are
we gonna get this shape yo let's try
something let's try something let's um
let's bevel this piece right so we have
our bevel again and remember that like
remember this little graph right here
let's let's mess with this so for
whatever reason well so for whatever
reason it's giving us this little like
little top hat thing here why why is
that happening
sometimes you guys just gotta mess with
these settings I don't know why that's
happening oh maybe that's why that's cuz
I see yeah it's because um this top
piece is being extruded or beveled to
the point where it's just it's just had
to it's just had it it's just had too
much and it's imploding on itself that's
why that's why you know what happens it
happens let's get down here let's get
down to this uh this guy around
alright so round makes it kind of look
like a bullet and that is looking close
honestly I think we can we can say that
is fine let's give it let's give it ten
more so ten subdivision so you have ten
little cross-sections going up to the
top of this thing which looks very close
the only difference is that it it wings
out at the edge so let's um let's say
that's good right and then let's do that
scale trick again where we scale by with
soft selection so
let us select all of these cross
segments so I'm hitting you and then L
and that will let me do a loop selection
so if you go to select and you select
the loop selection option option here
you'll see right next to it ul
that's your hotkey for it and that's
gonna let you just select all the little
loops here and I'm holding shift to make
my way downtown walk real fast got it
and we're gonna scale those guys we're
gonna scale them now if I just go to
town and I scale it you see how it's
getting smaller on the y-axis we don't
want that so we're gonna untie GLE the
y-axis right here so then you'll see
it'll like scale more properly and if we
enable soft selection and we crank the
strength to a hundred and the radius
down to 20 we should be able to get some
sort of spire looking shape where it
Flay's out let's change it from Bell to
dome that's it that's the shape we want
so let's take the radius down to like 10
so it's really just gonna get that last
piece there sweet yeah
and then let's make the top let's go up
here and just scale the top piece here
because it comes more to a point and
we'll set the bell the radius to like 30
and let's bow out let's bow out this
middle piece too like we're really just
trying to get you know guys maybe I were
talking about different ways of doing
things
I just figured out a better way let's
see this through and we'll walk back and
then I'll get back to you guys as
questions here because I haven't forgot
about those this looks chunky man it
this looks like a looks like some janky
Crayola like yeah let's let's not do
this here's the shape guys we're gonna
draw it with a pen tool pen tool right
next to the primitives let's go into
that side view let's sneak up on here in
here and we could reference we could
reference the bell but and we should
write we know that it does something
like this and it comes down like that
and then it comes up like that probably
something like something like that and
then you got you know you want to
complete the complete circuit boom let's
come in here and make sure that we don't
have this crazy little wing wing edane
here you gotta hit the move tool to grab
these guys we only want to affect one
side so you're gonna hold shift to make
that right you want this point to be
exactly in line with this point so
notice at the bottom down here you have
these numbers you will notice that the
so the x-axis on the red or it's saying
it's Z you
is this number here we can literally
just copy this number so like that paste
that number and now we know they're
stacked perfectly on top of each other
because you'll see we'll do this in a
second and then this point right here
you want this point to be exactly the
same on the y-axis as this point right
here you want a 90-degree angle perfect
so we'll notice okay this point 305
point one five eight copy that paste it
well that's perfect so now all you have
to do now all you have to do is select
that spline you just made see we made
the shape right it looks better than
this little Crayola crayon here we're
gonna take this shape we're gonna hold
alt because you know what here let's
take that back we're gonna make
something called a lathe lathe nerve or
lathe object and the lathe is basically
like it's gonna take this shape and it's
going to wrap it around so when you drop
the spline into that interesting uh I
know why I know why it's because it
needs to work from the center of like
the world so basically you know you have
your spline this point right here you
want to just Center that up zero zero
zero so you'll come down let's see yeah
you see how it's wrapping it around
there give me give me two shakes here
yeah we basically want the the anchor
point to be right in that corner so you
know and this isn't this is a case where
you need it to be perfect and I'll tell
you why it let's say we do it like this
let's say we take the anchor point we
move it there it's not perfect it's just
off a little bit and then we sent to the
object boom okay it's centered and then
we do the lathe Nirvan it and you can
see oh there's a hole through the middle
technically this would work for us
because it's so far away but let's say
you don't want that hole so what you
would need to do is let's see what you
would need to do is select your spline
and instead of eyeballing this exactly
because there's always gonna be a tiny
little piece we are off right you can go
up here to the axis Center tool click
that and now we're saying we want it to
be correct on the z axis
you see the z axis is blue it's going
that way so let's zero out the Y X the Y
is fine we execute alright we just did
that it brought it up to the middle all
right we don't want that we do want the
Y to be at the bottom so you bring the Y
boom all the way down to the bottom it
is the bottom most point of your object
and we want the z-axis or here to be
positive so it's going that way so we
want to make sure that numbers are
positive execute boom now it's exactly
on the corner there we can now reset our
object reset PSR to zero that's another
another little button that love shift
see hit PSR reset PSR there it is if you
don't know where it is I don't I don't
know where it is that's why I put it
there
and again if you guys do that you make
your custom buttons and you want to keep
them there for the next time you open
cinema 4d go to window customization
save as startup layout and you'll be
good to go for the next time let's
finish the spire let's go and answer
some questions all right all right all
right all right let's do this
well we got a lot of questions sweet
guys um hello from Denmark what's up
Denmark I don't know what you guys you
can tree guys counting okay oh you you
guys are trying to guess the focal
length oh my goodness
alright umm that's hilarious
56 57 who knows guys who knows hello
from Oklahoma what's up Oklahoma um low
five beats to render - absolutely you
know the reason I didn't put any on for
this stream is because one I can't hear
what I'm playing in other words I can't
test what it sounds like on the stream
maybe we'll get to that point and I'm
sure I will once I do some more of this
also you know you guys play your own
music put your music on but I'll
probably be playing some music on the
next stream you ever think about doing a
quarter video involving your ability to
make an awesome sound sound effects with
your voice you could do a police academy
parody or something absolutely yes I
think it'd be awesome to do a voice only
sound effects video I thought about that
for a long time how did I get into
photography so I've always shot my short
films on this channel the Punisher
channel and I love it I love making
stuff look awesome I love movies that
look awesome so it's it's a passion for
me and it's something that I want to do
you know so you know from the very
beginning my brother had a tiny little
camera it had a video mode on it that's
how I started out my first videos that I
uploaded it like MySpace
but um I was interested in video first
and then got to the point where I've
shot enough stuff that like you know I
was like oh this looks cool this looks
awesome I can make it look cooler if I
just move the camera down a little bit
more work on my composition because I'm
trying to tell stories I'm trying to I'm
trying to express emotion through video
through film right and you can you can
do that by you know hitting one angle
versus another and once they started
realizing that like oh cool so you can
really get people to feel a certain way
based on the way you shoot based on the
lighting you use but
on your composition so I deal really
hard into that and you know started
looking all these tutorials and reading
books on all that and man honestly it
was more just the passion of at first I
didn't get into the books until a little
bit later but like just taking a picture
that looked awesome was and especially
now with Instagram you know you upload
it to Instagram you get some comments on
it and stuff it's the feeling of making
a short film but much faster making a
short film is so much work
oh my goodness and eventually want to
make a feature film that's gonna be so
much work but with a picture it's so
much faster you can you can get you can
hit all those points of like creative
fulfillment through a photograph and
uploading with comments and sharing to
you guys and answering questions you can
get all that fulfillment from just a
photo so I like that's why I like
photography is because it can translate
an emotion and it's very it's it's a
passion for me and it's something I can
do pretty quickly it's the best you know
it's just the best and then I got into
film photography because my buddy Jan
was like here try this and from there I
just loved it
do you have your sketches up as well
somewhere I the only place I have my
drawings is on Instagram and it'd be
cool to have you know another website
for my drawings but at this point in in
my life
I don't draw as much just because I'm
putting my my skill points or you know
my time into other areas like like
cinema 4d you know or making cool
textures and stuff so it's really just
about how I'm toning my time right now
that's um that is CG work a lot of VFX
and whatnot you guys know I have a
full-time job at corridor digital so
that's most that's basically most of my
time right there you know but yeah I
still love like I mean you know you guys
know a huge part of chorded corridor
digital is the VFX side and the
technical side so I gotta stay brushed
up on that and sometimes if you want to
if you want to excel and get better you
may not have time to learn at work you
know you'll be fortunate if you're in a
situation where you can push yourself to
the next level at work because that's
not efficient right
I remember the first shot I did in
cinema 4d was for the prim tech videos
here I'll pull it up for you guys real
quick and I'll show you how long it took
me to do one shot let's see the zombie
meat harvester video this one right here
so it's the final shot
yes it's meat with an apple in my mouth
okay so where's where's the shot here is
yeah this one so the meat sliding down
the chute this was the first shot I did
in c4d after like six years of not using
it and now oh my goodness this wood that
that shot would probably take me like an
hour maybe the rendering time might take
more than the time it would take to like
do the shot but it took me a week to do
this shot it took me so long I literally
didn't have time to to save my like my
composition my after effect shot I had
to have I think I rendered the shot and
left for the airport
it was so crunched on time and you know
a lot of jobs like it's awesome because
corridor you know they were all about
experimenting and figuring out figuring
out like the best way to do stuff and
getting on top of the top of the craft
right and that's not possible unless you
spend time to get better and a lot of
jobs it might be seen oh you're wasting
time you know you're not being as
proactive as possible you don't know how
to do something well we hired you we
hired you for the things you know how to
do not things you don't know how to do
so why are you wasting time learning
like this I get it to an extent right
but it's not like that a corridor so
it's awesome it's the best and they let
me they let me figure this out one week
for this one shot the point I'm trying
to make is it would have been possible
if I didn't look up tutorials beforehand
I still had to look up tutorials while I
was doing this
shot for that week but it was only
possible because I was watching
tutorials in my free time grayscale
guerilla tutorials right and you just
have to invest the time just like with
anything you have to invest the time to
get better at something consistently and
that's the only reason I'm here you know
you know flowing through this program to
show you guys stuff is because I
invested the time to learn the thing got
to make the time got to make time no
matter what it is workout eating healthy
learning a new program got to invest the
time so like I was saying about sketches
I don't have time I don't the time to
invest in the sketches right now but you
know I'll always be drilling for sure
always be drawing I'll always be
rendering I'll always be making stuff
I'll always be directing I'll always be
shooting so you guys can count on that
oh hello Sondra what's up dude
how Sondra been so long so long in
Alessandro is a very very talented VFX
artist he worked on Metal Gear Solid
philanthropy if you guys know what that
is
look it up it's amazing
do ASMR VFX stream it could be
interesting
it could be interesting how's work been
works been awesome and learning a lot
been challenged so that's always good
gotta be challenged
it's a rule it's a real treat coming
into the office and having things you
know you're not doing the same thing
every day right come into the office you
play a video game for node you go
airsoft for node Oh now today I'm
working on you know rendering and
creating a realistic robot the other day
I'm writing the next day you know you're
one wheeling to lunch and having a good
time like it's awesome so I like I love
it there it's amazing
let's see someone's looking for the
website URL yo its noise green and light
calm boom always green and light calm
got the photography there scroll through
it go to the little contact page guys
look how serious this picture is guess
serious that is
I'm taking myself so seriously in this
one but yeah leave a little contact
right here throw in your name and email
leave me a message let me know that
you're here from the stream I've got the
Instagram there I got the store got the
collections and I got plans for this
website this year so I'm very very
excited to be continuing this I want to
put a VFX I want to put out a VFX
website as well this year so big plans
good times
what else we got what else we got guys
tips on how to learn 3d modeling and
animation find the program you want to
use whether it be blender cinema 4d 3ds
max I mean I highly recommend cinema 4d
I'm using it now blender is awesome cuz
it's free between those two you'll be
set Google tutorials that you want to
see for those programs or leave a
comment here asking for tutorials I'll
make a tutorial for you guys that's the
whole point of this thing once a week
the whole year let's go then follow this
tutorial follow along in the tutorial if
you have the program pulled up you know
be following along and see that you
you'll soon realize that you can create
something awesome pretty quickly and
that is very satisfying start a little
Instagram account you guys you guys know
people right people has posted to
Instagram every single day for the last
12 years hasn't missed the day and has
been cinema 40 it's all just cinema 4d
stuff and he used it as a way to just
practice and you know repetition
consistency because that's the stuff is
gonna make you better consistency and
repetition use Instagram to post your
stuff every day
it's called every day renders and
there's a lot of people doing it and if
you are consistent with it you will get
so much better
it took me it took me like let's say a
year of consistent work with cinema 4d
and I felt like I'm just flying through
the program is the best it's not going
you that long but just hop in it's fun
what else other questions are the
questions when the next time chordal or
yourself will be in Minnesota the snow
beckons you all oh my goodness guys I
loved Minnesota when I was out there
with corridor I love me some snow
but um I don't know who knows I'm sure
we'll be out there again at some point
can you call out the keys you're using
no joke I'm working on a rooftop shot
for my movie this is perfect help yes I
will definitely hit the keys hit the hot
keys as I continue this spirited away
castle with corridor digital acquiring
node will we see you in more videos over
there you're hilarious in spy fall
thanks dude
Zoran Zotto appreciate it dude yeah for
sure I am I've already been in more node
episodes this year then I've been in
probably the last quarter of last year
so absolutely um turn on limit you
talking about the audio limit like a
compressor so it doesn't get too loud or
too quiet Chris Schmidt wait a second
Chris Schmidt you mean like rocket lasso
Chris Schmitt like former grayscale
gorilla maestro Chris MIT yeah it can't
be but if it is oh my god what an honor
thank you
he's here guys hope maybe maybe I don't
know if it's the same Chris Smith good
afternoon
konbanwa konichiwa I've been taking
Japanese class um no cyber has allowed
cyber hats um let's see the effects ok
ok now ok guys now we're getting to some
spire yes I'm with that spire huh okay
dang you guys leaving a lot of comments
I appreciate you guys as so many so many
questions to answer here what influenced
me to move over to working at corridor
man I love those guys I think we have a
lot of creative crossover and I have a
lot to learn there so it
to me seem like a very good a good
experience or a good opportunity to go
over there and learn as much as I can of
my VFX game now this year I'm in the
process of upping my writing game
because at the end of the day man
writing is the hardest thing for me
directing I have a lot more experience
with I'm a lot more comfortable
directing but when it comes to writing
it's very difficult you're not gonna
have a good story without a good script
and you need actors to you know bring it
to the next level so I'm working on my
writing this year hi from Australia I
hope you guys are still not on fire
I heard it's rough over there I hope you
guys are all right I hope to visit there
one day what else
ragdoll physics okay uh hello from
Vancouver also another place I want to
visit her it's beautiful heard you had
some nice bike paths okay if you could
summarize what your specialty is with
cinema 4d and VFX
what would it be I love making things
look as photo-real as possible so I'd
say photo realism would be my specialty
with After Effects in cinema 4d
I love texturing in cinema 4d is one of
my favorite things ever is texturing
making things look real and lighting it
and you know having using all of the the
VFX know how to bring that into a
live-action plate a lot of people just
do use cinema 4d and render what they
have at a cinema 4d and it's like
amazing you're like Toy Story is a good
example not that they use cinema 4d but
like they're not combining you know
woody or Buzz Lightyear with live-action
plates that's what you would be doing if
you were doing transformers right so I'd
say my specialty is making things like
photo real in cinema and combining it
compositing it with live-action plates
and After Effects
I'm finally back where we've been dude
I've been I have been working I was at
rocketjump I was then I was doing
freelance now I'm at corridor and it's
just it's feels so nice to be back on
this channel and like putting because
it's here you know it's like it's an
established channel and I want to be
putting more love into it so it wouldn't
make sense not to and I'm I kind of got
stuck in the sense that all the shorts
that I posted on this channel they were
so big and like I got to a point where
it's like I can't go any bigger with the
resources I have so I it stopped me from
making tutorials but I'm sorry not
tutorials it's not me from making short
films because I felt like I had to go
bigger and better and if the lat and if
the next video wasn't as bigger it's
better than the last it was it would be
seen as not as good so I had to realize
that you know just doing something is
better than nothing and that's what
that's what this is and not that it's
like a cop out or anything but I really
do think that this info here the VFX and
the tutorial stuff I think it's just a
great way to hop back in and share my
info with you guys and get back to you
guys cuz you know it's really cool that
you guys have stuck around for this long
Maxim website says assemble 40 is 60
months annual payment so it's actually
720 for the year yeah it's a little
pricey you know compared to blender
which is free but I love it I freaking
love it see for to you the best is this
piece for fun yes it is hyper Sapien
wait that sounds familiar
that sounds really familiar hyper sapien
do you know red do you know do you know
Casey maybe
is that we find out if Cushman is the
real Krish MIT I'd like to believe it is
alright y'all I am hopping back in let's
get back to it so I've been talking so
much talking talking talking so much it
is not a dong you dirty people it's a
bell tower okay that that might be more
okay we'll get rid of that
so hotkeys right for moving and scaling
things T is for scale e is your move
tool and r is for rotation and you can
find any hotkey by hovering over the
little button here so move tool rights
as e next to it is T and rotation is our
alright so I'm hitting T to bring up the
scale tool E to bring up the move tool
and then we're just gonna kind of like
shape shape this piece out here you can
make it editable and ul if I hit ul
that's your let's see that is your loop
selection tool so that's gonna allow you
to select you know a ring around
whatever we want to hit M and T that's
an extrude inner we want to extrude
sorry M M W I get those mixed up
sometimes M W we want an extra inner
right because we see this bell tower and
then M T for an extrude so you can get
that get that look right there and if
you feel like this needs to be a little
skinnier then you can just kind of undo
that hit M W again and then MT to bring
it down now it's doing some funky stuff
at the bottom like it's coming out in
little tears so we're just going to
extrude inner again MW bring it out MT
for extrude and then just repeat the
process for the last little chunk here
and there you go and the top the top
looks like it has a little spire so that
again you know there's a bunch of
different ways to do that but it looks
like we have a little spire sized a
little piece there and I'm just gonna
scale that extrude let me extrude that M
T so I hit em you can see if you hit T
down on this list extrude and just scale
it whoa what the heck just happened is
it doing what is it doing
oh it's the is it the angle offset I
don't know why is it doing that you see
what I'm talking about it's like it's
like coning weird well I'm a scale it a
little bit and then I'm just gonna
straight-up cheat and move it and there
you go
so we're at the point now we're like we
want to start getting into the lighting
so let's see let's um let's scale this
back let's get this the right proportion
scaled down to there we can make it a
little skinnier and then it looks like
right next to it I'm holding ctrl and
spawning a cylinder right on that object
and then like right next to it looks
like we have a little little guy there
and off to the side it looks like we
have another one just right off there
but it's like way smaller I'm hitting T
again to bring up the scale tool e to
bring up the move tool and let's see
yeah that's looking about right so you
you want to be saving your work
constantly constantly save your work all
right let's give me the lighting here
because this on the right does not look
like this picture here this beautiful
wonderful Miyazaki piece of art so
a couple things we are going to want to
use we have fog involved we have fog
right here we have blue lighting and it
looks like it's very overcast there is a
sunset it's back there so let's let's
start with an HDR eye now since I'm
using octane octane has all of its own
right and for those of you guys who
don't know octane is a renderer and it
you know it's up against Arnold and it's
up against redshift those are the three
main renders that I know of personally
right now there's some other stuff like
blender has it something but so all the
lighting stuff since it's part of the
renderer it's gonna be its own like
thing so you have an octane sky
environment versus just a sky
environment you're gonna an octane light
versus just a light you're gonna have
octane materials versus just materials
and it's basically the same thing it's
just you know it's own code and has its
own little special bells and whistles so
in this case we're gonna do an octane
sky and you'll get to that if you if any
of you guys have octane honestly I doubt
any of you guys have c40 or octane in
this chat right now but if you do just
shout it out real quick let's see then
you're gonna want to go to materials and
you're gonna want to go to let's see
you're gonna go to object hgri
environment and that's gonna make your
octane sky we're real quick David I hear
you man no offense to the people
watching that want to that one step by
step instructions i'd much rather watch
you go over your general principles and
discuss your pipeline while you make
your 3d model tonight that's very
interesting um I could certainly do that
a little bit yeah that makes sense to me
so like I was literally like I was just
saying I doubt that you guys have cinema
4d and octane so what that's actually
David I think is a really good way to
make this more accessible to all of you
guys is talking about the general flow
of things versus like I'm hitting this
button I'm clicking this number you know
you guys can see you guys can see what
I'm doing here and I will still do that
but let's just say for the next five
minutes let's let's try and talk more
generally okay so how would I do that
um you know we want to get the lighting
right so you can do that in a couple
different ways you can use an HDR eye
environment which gets you you know
different kind of lighting setups here I
actually have a pretty good one from
greyscale gorilla the ultimate skies
pack and you know you click on any of
these and you can just see what it does
here boom and I just want to get the
feel of this picture right now so it
looks like the Sun is right back in
there and I'm gonna go through some
different HDR eyes to make sure that the
lighting is right you know there's some
that are brighter there's some that are
more dim I think there's some like
overcast ones too this one yeah it's a
little green on the green side but we
can fix that
ooh that's a little looking a little
spooky oh these ones could be cool
yeah my goal for you guys would be to
like have you recreate this kind of
stuff in your own programs because not
everyone has this stuff but let's find
the right you wanna you want to find the
right look the right the right sky in
our case let me let me get some lights
on in this place one sec guys
all right so we can always change this
lighting at any point but it'll be nice
to get it locked in release something to
work with you know
let's go with this yeah let's let's try
this image right now so it looks to me
like this picture it's there's like a
layer of fog down here that is obscuring
the the the bath house from like
touching the ground right and same over
here so what I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna like make some mountains for the
bath house to like be on you know and
same for the right side I'm gonna make a
little mountain thing here and even the
back left I'll do some mountains and
then I'll obscure that with some fog and
then I'll start really messing with the
lighting and then hopefully we can wrap
this thing out pretty quick so let's
let's make a little mountain and
cinema4d has a really cool landscape
thing here which allows you to make some
sweet mountains and stuff so that'll be
a way for us to boom to start hiding
this mountain and I'm looking at the
bottom right here you can see the
silhouette we're getting is pretty cool
yeah that's that's looking pretty cool
and then I'm gonna just control drag it
out and scale it up a little bit and
just try and connect it to this bridge
here and really as long as it looks good
in the silhouette
you'll be okay it doesn't actually have
to connect so we're just trying to get
we're just trying to get a nice result
on the silhouette versus a like a
polygon accurate kind of thing you know
well there goes my daylight thing it's
gonna start wigging out switching
between daylight and let's disable flux
for a second here and then let's go to
let's push these mountains back in the
back and just make a little bit of
something back here just
some for some perspective sweet so now
what I'm gonna do here is add a fog
layer and the fog is really gonna tie
this all together so hopefully okay this
is when my computer starts chugging so
if c40 crashes you know we'll just boot
it right back up so there's your fog
it's really dense we need to spread it
out over this whole region here so let's
let's first turn it down real quick
because it's about to get intense we
don't want it to blow out our system
here so scale it up you can hide it from
the renderer which is what I'm gonna do
you're only gonna be able to see it in
the viewport here and it is a lower fog
so it's something like that yeah that's
gonna be sweet yeah that's gonna be
awesome but let's see what this looks
like
those mountains in the back will see
you'll see you'll see what sky look like
here let's turn it on and hope it
doesn't explode all right yeah not bad
at all so this is looking really dark
basically with cinema each other tweak
these settings here if you had a medium
and you click this image let's just
bring the density down to like 1 and we
can actually set it to like a cloud I
think fog medium or no cloud 1 yeah
and that gives it a bit of definition as
you guys can see there and then yeah we
need to bring the density back down here
but it needs to be thick enough that you
don't see the ground here so let's see
we'll set it to like I don't know two or
something yeah that's looking pretty
nice and and the vibe here right is in
this image everything is pretty uniform
and it looks like the sky and the fog
blend into each other and then you have
this silhouette that emerges from the
fog so that's what we're gonna go for so
we need to start tweaking our like color
settings and whatnot because this does
not look like the image so let's see
let's see let's make a Sun light swivel
it around and we want to include our
I'll turn the turbidity so it's more of
an overcast kind of deal and we'll
change the sky color will reference the
actual like painting here and we will we
want to include mix our sky texture and
our HDRI together so you're getting both
[Music]
let's see we don't want to see our
sunlight we want to see our HDR eye so
how would we do that
hmm we could set our background the
octane background to visible environment
okay so that's gonna show that's gonna
show through the background but it's not
being used to light the scene so the
primary environment lights the scene
what we'll do then is we'll just
duplicate that and we'll set the other
one too visible environment so that
we're getting one to affect the lighting
and want to just be the background so we
want the fog we're gonna change the
color the fog scattering and absorption
that's what needs to change so we want
to go for like that blue-green kind of
vibe like this and then we can brighten
it up and even brighter even wider and
the hgri should be a bit brighter too
because our image is pretty dark here we
want the bathhouse to be darker than the
fog the fog needs to be pretty light so
this is just you know tweaking we're
tweaking settings here to find the right
the right look
um so let's see here
maybe it's scattering phase yeah there
you go so you can start to crank that up
and you'll see you'll start to see it
get a little bit brighter and be
affected by that Sun a little bit more
well okay that's that's too much and I
think on top of this I'm gonna do like a
general layer of fog above this
lower-lying fog here and then let's just
for the sake of this look here let's
make a material for the bath house and
we'll make it like a let's reference the
actual photo so let's make it the color
of the photo there and we'll drop it on
let's go okay so organization is key
right we're gonna want to group all of
the geometry that makes up this bath
house scene together so we have all
these pieces that aren't the camera or
the hgri that make up this thing and
we're just gonna want to group those
together and throw the texture on it so
it's looking a little darker which is
nice but we still need to bring up the
general atmosphere of the shot we can do
that a couple ways but I think the first
thing I'm gonna do let's name this to
like ground fog and let's let's
duplicate it and we're gonna make a like
top fog for up here and this fog will be
a lot more like see-through and this
will start to give us the feeling that's
pretty foggy
all right now we're starting to get
there I think if we changed out the if
we changed out the background I'm not
really feeling the background right now
so let's let's get that right I think
something brighter
so at this point okay okay I'm feeling
that yeah I'm feeling that for sure
that's looking pretty sweet
what's the bottom one okay let's see
what else we got
it's a really nice like early-morning
kind of feeling let's see about maybe
this one right here ooh that's a good
one too it's a good one to shoot yeah
that's awesome see that matches the like
the lighting of the painting a bit more
you have that low lying like sunrise
sunset vibe right let's let's hide all
this fog from the viewport so we can see
what we're doing okay but you can still
see how it is darker and we can we can
bring this up in a couple different ways
like we talked about the first thing I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna boost the
exposure let's go to like let's go to
three let's go to four yeah and you're
starting to bring up the image here
specifically with octane you do want to
adjust the let's see where's my settings
here should be the GI clamp yeah Jake
lamp is at one you see it we're seeing a
little like speckles here and with
octane specifically you can bring down
[Music]
the what is it there's a slider how
pixel removal yeah we can bring that
down and with fog you get that it's a
very render intensive
how're you guys doing
how's everybody doing mmm what a VDB
look better than regular fog well I
guess VDB VDB file is to my knowledge a
file that is basically like a volume
file so you can get like a cloud versus
like a blanketed straight piece of fog
so in this case a VT v would look a
little bit better
which is kind of what we're using
because we are you know we changed it
from a just fog to a cloud one the cloud
one button basically and that gives it a
bit more texture just like in the image
you can see how you know that you can
see the little individual puffs and
whatnot so yeah
btv would work better than general fog
but fog always works just pretty much as
well what else is going on heck yeah
dude get to it Deano make that castle on
this guy do I make mood boards before I
begin a project so it really depends on
what I'm doing like I'd say generally
generally no I don't but I have a
reference you know I will have some sort
of reference as to what I'm trying to
recreate or trying to get the feeling of
um so in a sense it's a mood board but
it's just like a mood photo right it's
just one references helped me a lot if
especially if you're trying to text or
something you know reference the real
life thing always reference the real
life stuff because for me I'm trying to
get that photo real look and it's not
gonna look photo real if you don't
reference something photo real always
always always when you're doing VFX or
when you're doing any sort of art
reference the real thing
it just helps and it gets you to the
next level there's a lot of tiny details
that you'll miss if you don't reference
the real thing and we could go and we
could reference like what you know a
foggy
castle looks like but for this case I'm
trying to recreate this image and for me
that's enough right this looks beautiful
enough but we're still not there right
it has this painterly look and that's
something that you're gonna get in
Photoshop but I want to get my colors
right you know it has this bright look
to it and it's a it's very soft it's you
you know your your contrast doesn't push
too hard
it is generally bright and your sky does
transition into your fog so I want to
see if I can focus on that right now
transitioning my sky into my fog so
that's pretty that's pretty tough I
think with this with this background I
think I can change the color of my fog I
think that's what I need to do is work
on that so let me just jump in here and
start messing messing with that
all right
so I honestly I get you mixed up the the
scattering in the absorption but I do
know that it brings color into account
so if I set let's just say I set both of
these to the color of say like this fog
right here it looks really dark and that
is certainly not what we're going for so
let's say I made one of them white what
would that look like
if I bring that up okay so that doesn't
make it brighter it just kind of makes
it more D saturated so let's take a step
back and see where we can go from here
let's let's change the other one let's
change the other one to a brighter blue
okay well that whoa okay that does not
look good let's take the saturation out
of that and maybe what we need to do is
instead of like trying to match the
picture perfectly let's see if we can't
match the fog to our sky a bit better so
let's start referencing the color of our
sky in our HDR i versus the sky in the
painting because they're different you
not going to get them exact
go get both of these okay so that's like
that's really intense from what I've
seen tutorial wise is you want to get
your absorption to be like a brighter
version of the scattering so I know this
is pretty might be pretty boring for you
guys at this point but do you need to
get this right if we want to continue
because that is the fee this is the
feeling of the image
okay yeah that's not that's not looking
at bad let's push this fog layer out a
bit more our sky fog right so we have
our sky fog layer we'll bring that down
a little bit and see if we can't blend
the sky with the fog a bit more so
that's what our sky fog is doing
I'm making another one here and I'm just
bringing it way back behind the the
bathhouse to silhouette it even more
this is pretty intense
hmm I liked it a bit more before
actually so this is tough yeah this is
just like trial and error trying to
tweak these settings
alright I've messed with the camera a
little bit
I love throwing a little vignette on
there but that doesn't feel right
let's see if we can't tweak some of our
are let's here see we can't find
something that feels nice
okay that's kind of getting in the vibe
there the portrait
let's adjust the contrast a little bit
so like take the 2.2 down like a 1.8 or
something 1.5 and then we can check the
white point so it's a very turquoise
kind of feeling now I think you go
opposite of turquoise so the opposite of
turquoise is like I don't know
magenta I guess then you get more of a
kind of a green blue if we want blue we
go yellow
let's see now Yale is magenta so magenta
this is tough
something let's see so it's a Bluegreen
we're trying to go forward you want to
go the opposite so let's start with blue
we want go the opposite of blue which is
yellow and if you make it yellow it'll
turn blue but that looks magenta to me
but I am colorblind so let's see
let's do so yellow is turning let's go
orange or an orangish red I don't know
is that doing anything yeah red we'll go
to green just pink we'll go a little
blue take a saturation up a little oh
that's bad I think we need more color in
our fog here so it's definitely like
this turquoise kind of look
and then let's maybe see about just
changing out the sky once again I think
this one's all in the sky and you know
it might be better to do the sky in
Photoshop but okay okay okay okay here
we go here we go this is feeling this is
feeling a little better
see that's much brighter
let's work with this so we want the
overall color let's see if is the Sun
doing anything for us weird okay so the
sunlight is making things darker
okay this is looking pretty cool
well
this looks intense
oh my goodness it is Chris MIT holy crap
dude awesome man freaking awesome I
learned so much from that guy so many
dynamics how to do like gravity and you
know dynamic setups that you know you
have like a tank with that rolls on its
treads and goes over rocks and stuff
like a bunch of crazy awesome stuff with
dynamics and gravity instead of a 48
Christian man that's awesome thanks for
thanks for stopping by dude I'm just
trying to do a little little little
studio ghibli render here man trying to
get that vibe right trying to get the
feeling right so I think I like it with
the sunlight let's just crank the size
of this thing
whoa whoa that looks crazy what the heck
well what do we do
that's feeling like some early-morning
vibes to me here I mean that's that's
that's kind of it you know like we could
even throw some lights in this thing but
that's not necessary we could throw some
trees in here if we wanted let's do that
real quick let's throw some quick trees
up in this thing how would we do that
well let's just make a new project real
quick we're gonna make our own tree and
it's gonna be the dankest tree you'd
ever seen and it probably won't even
resemble a tree it's gonna look more
like let's see so we have a plane we're
gonna make a leaf we're gonna make it
zero by zero so it's just these like
four points and we'll scale it way down
and we will let's see let's see let's
see we will take this and duplicate it a
lot so we could do that by using a
cloner
so with this cloner we can just do like
a grid array right so we have all these
pieces we'll do 10 by 10 by 10 and scale
these guys down and we'll bring them all
together scale them back up a little bit
more and then we'll use an effector
called a random effector and the random
effector is basically gonna randomize
the position the rotation the scale so
we have the position randomized that's
great
we want to randomize the rotation 360 by
360 by 360 and that's that's basically
your treat
yeah let's do the scale 2.1 right let's
try one what does one look like sure
sure
it's so far away like you're not gonna
be able to tell group all this stuff
we'll copy it over into our other two
where we get what's called a bathroom
why is this final bathroom the heck it
will paste it in there and there you go
you got a tree let's give it the same
let's give it the same material and let
us place it right I'll place it over
[Music]
just the front of this thing so we'll
scale it down and you got a tree there
let's see what looks like in the
silhouette there's your tree right that
little guy right there
now you could scatter that all around
the whole place but I don't think it's
necessary you guys get the idea you have
a really cool like painterly look to
this and we could do that in Photoshop
so I'm gonna see this out and finish it
in Photoshop real quick so I also want
to throw some film green on it because
you know John Green is cool and all
[Music]
let's see let's grab this mountain and
the back left I don't really like how
its feeling so I'm gonna scale it up
like that same for this one here it
feels a little too like polygonal so I'm
gonna just tweak some quick settings
here
and if it's a little difficult to see
you can switch between your lighting
modes by going up to the display options
here and switching friends like these
first four and you'll you can see the
hot key and a and B and C you're in D so
I'll just kind of flip through until
it's feeling right this feels good to me
here so it's just a little too spiky for
me so you can mess with the with
segments or the rough furrows and fine
furrows and kind of get that down a
little bit you know we can scale those
up a little let's go back to our camera
view and see what that looks like
yeah that feels a little better I'm
using render region right here just to
quickly get to what we're looking at
here and I think these hard edges will
certainly be smoothed out when we go
into Photoshop and do some like
painterly effects on it all right
CG geek awesome man thanks for joining
appreciate it man this is awesome I
can't wait to do this every week this is
gonna be great and we can get into some
like more detailed stuff too
and I'd love to figure out a way to get
your guys's feedback and requests so I
can figure out you know like what's the
best thing what's the best that's
tutorial to do for a stream here
you mean about some of those or
something and if you guys want to follow
me on instagram that is underscore
punisher underscore and we can have a
little discussion there as well maybe
figure out what to do next but I think
ultimately I want to do like a little
discord channel for this so we can
organize everybody's thoughts alright
what else needs to be done in this image
so we're seeing a lot of the definition
in this roof I kinda want to cut down
the definition we're seeing
and I think we can do that with a bit
more fog so I'm gonna take the ground
fog and we're gonna move it down and
then I'm just gonna get a little bit
more fog between the camera and the the
bathhouse so let's take a look at our
sky fog alright there's definitely
there's definitely something there for
sure let's just crank up the density so
from point point one I don't know let's
go to its gonna one see what one does
alright now we see nothing if we crank
up a scattering phase some of that light
will seep through okay
now it looks like we're underwater so
let's start walking back the density it
was at point one before let's try point
five
all right this is awesome yeah this is
this is really really cool we can so the
fog is pretty intense right now and we
have the scattering phase cranked so the
light will have more definition let's
take our ground fog and make it a bit
more dense as well the density is 3 ooh
yeah there we go so we need to bring
scattering phase back up we're getting
close guys
let's bring the sky fog density down
0.25 and see what we got dude that's
super close that's super super close
I'll try 0.3 0.35 and it looks like
there's some like fog up top here which
is like kind of an overcast day and the
clouds are sniping through the middle of
that so ooh I got an idea
I got an idea let's fruit NHGRI and see
what that does
um is it doing anything it kind of doing
its kind of doing something let's take
this sky fog yeah let's let's take the
sky fog and bring it down to 0.25 again
and the ground fog let's bring that down
two guys are just pushing and pulling
these numbers and we're getting close
kind of liked it a little bit more
before 0.35
sweet yeah definitely thing I'll
probably I'll probably post this on the
instagrams tomorrow morning or something
you know I'm gonna try something crazy
guys I'm gonna try something insane and
see if this works
um let us try and get some more light
coming through the center of this thing
so what if like what if I just made a
light this is gonna be ridiculous if I
made a light and I turned it way down
let's turn it way down and let's push it
way back and let's have it just be like
a horizon light like this and let's make
it the color of the sunlight real quick
so in octane you'll just use an RGB
spectrum and you'll set the color to
your sunlight well that's so crazy it's
kind of green
and then let's bring the intensity back
up to like 2000 that's that's that's a
little weird let's let's try bringing it
up a little bit more
yeah that's probably a little too much
well we tried
um let's see
let's split maybe not give up so soon um
you see how you're seeing it like you're
seeing the streak of light I don't want
to see that so we use an octane tag and
we'll turn off the visibility here so
now you're not seeing the streak you're
just seeing like the after-effects of
are you still seeing it I can't tell I
cannot honestly cannot tell
oh my goodness yeah this is Gilbert this
is my new little cat he's such a
friendly little buddy do you have
anything to say Gilbert no oh he's a
cute little bud
such a cute bud hey that light works
that light works I think I will I think
I'll keep that Oh
all right Gilbert are you gonna hang out
are you gonna he's gonna chill my
shoulder you wants to hang out but he
makes it difficult to do the effects
Gilbert fix with one hand hey bud
all right so yes I hear you on this this
mountain
it's a looking a little too splotchy so
let's bring it forward just enough so
that let's see where you at where you at
mountain top view wait what what
happened okay there you are yeah let's
just bring you forward a little bit and
let's rotate the lights a little that's
what the light is a little heavy on the
right side because I think there's no
fog on the right side that would be my
guess
and I'll turn it down like just one I
think we're good
I think we can render this and finish it
in Photoshop so the rendering is gonna
take a minute but I can answer some
questions if you guys have any how many
questions while we render here let's get
this set up so usually I like to run
your stuff in 4k I will do a 4k version
later but for the sake here let's
through 1920 by 810 cuz we go in
widescreen current frame yes indeed
octane renderer and let's just go to
like EXR or something let's go to that
desktop
oh I think I know it's called bathroom I
meant to say bath house but bathroom is
dead okay
let's render this guy and we will open
up Photoshop so you guys got any
questions on the process I can't wait to
come back next week and do this for you
guys it's gonna be awesome
how often do I do V effects outside of
corridor not so not too often it's more
like hobby stuff like this I'll come
home and I'll just do like a cool render
or something so on my Instagram I do a
lot of photography a lot of film
photography but recently it's been some
like renders but I've been rendering you
know like little excerpts from my
favorite author Haruki Murakami from
some of his books and all like bring
those to life through cinema 4d and
octane so you can see those on my
Instagram that's underscore punished or
underscore and this will be the next one
I'll post this one up next but yeah it's
usually just personal project stuff I'll
come home I'll work on textures and
whatnot hey girls how many gigabytes do
I have dedicated to my graphics card man
to be honest I don't know virtual Ram
1.4 gigs out of 4.9 gigs out of 8 gigs I
don't know one of those all I know is I
have a 1070 I have about on this
computer I think I have man it's been a
minute since I checked like 24 gigs of
RAM I think I think you know and just a
motherboard motherboard to match the
graphics card the gtx 1070 government
nice joan for now hey bud
[Music]
let's see what film camera do you use
thinking about getting the a1 okay
alright Gilbert Gilbert needs to be
taken at this at this moment Thanks so
I'm using the Nicor Matt ftn film camera
here um let's see yeah this guy right
here so this thing's awesome
it's a film camera 35 millimeter film
camera from the late 70s it's Japanese
it's a Nikon Nikkor Matt and yeah it's
my first one basically my only one it's
the one I use the most I have a couple
others and I'm still experimenting with
but this is the one man it's it's
awesome the reason I love it is because
well one it's film film has a really
nice look to it but if you can see let's
see if you can see here it's very simple
you know this is how you pull back you
load the next the next shot this is your
shutter button and this tells you how
many shots you have left there's thirty
six in a roll here this is how you
unwind your film to wind it back and you
know pull this to open up the back gate
piece this is your this little readout
here is your light meter so when it's in
the middle it's exposed properly and
it's a very simple camera so basically
right this is tough it's like very
backwards for me there's a little dot
right there and that's your shutter
speed when you where is it
it goes from 1000 that's bulb right so
you can hold the shutter down as long as
you want you know like one second
eighth of the second quarter of a second
all the way down to the thousandth of a
second so that's your shutter speed your
ISO or your a si is down here and this
matches
to the stock of film you have so right
now I have sin is still 50 B so that
means it is like 50 a si you know porch
or 400 is another good one
so you'll crank this up to 400 and other
than that you know you have your your
f-stop or your aperture on your length
on the lens itself and that's all you
have to worry about so it's very very
very simple
I've never exposed my own film but I'm
gonna do it for the first time for a
corridor crew episode and are actually
gonna do a whole episode dedicated to
film photography and show you guys like
how I got into it I'll break down the
camera I use you know very similar to I
just showed you guys and we'll go
through like the whole process of
exposing film getting on your computer
seeing what you can get and all that
stuff go from and we'll go from there
because the people you know you guys
have a lot of questions I get a lot of
questions on my Instagram how do I you
know how do I get into film what do I
get
and we'll kind of break all that stuff
down
let's see any other questions guys we're
still rendering we're about a third of
the way through but I think we can cut
this off pretty quick here
sir rent yo what's up Ren Ren just
entered the chat and once I'm here to
Ren
how was that ride they went on a one
wheel ride earlier today how long have I
been using cinema 4d how long did it
take me to get the hang of it
so I started in cinema 4d about 11 years
ago on release 10 and then I stopped
using C 40 and switched to 3ds max
because there was a lot more tutorials
for it but recently I'd say two years
ago I got back into c4d the guys at max
on hooked hooked us up with copies at at
corridor so that was a huge huge
blessing and I'd say yeah I've been I've
been in it for two years but for me to
get the hang the hang of it probably was
like a couple months I don't know you
just have to do enough VFX shots and
watch enough tutorials to put the
information into practice and really
memorize all this stuff so it's just
repetition in consistency and dedication
to learning a new task if you do a shot
a day for 30 days you will you'll be
great
seriously you'll really pick up quickly
how to use the program just watch
tutorials go to greyscale gorilla or um
you know Chris Schmidt he just came out
with his own thing to rocket lasso I
think it was last year I think that's
right real quick rocket lasso yeah
oh he's streaming live he's streaming
live to check this out rocket lasso this
is Chris MIT so he does a lot of cool
stuff too man oh he's on twitch that's
awesome so there's a lot of there's a
lot of good resources you know there's
um there's AI design I'll show you guys
I design these guys are awesome but
honestly if you want to learn c4d you
can go to david our use website david ru
and go to his resources tab and his
resources tab
as a collection of the best tutorials
for c40 in octane he is the master
like they don't call him octane Jesus
for no reason this guy's the best and I
know he posts tutorials on I design as
well he works with EJ I'm a huge fan of
I've only met once but you know maybe
maybe this year at NAB we will meet
again but yeah these are awesome
resources here and of course grayscale
guerrilla love this love this site I've
learned so much from these guys that's
how I found out about Chris Schmidt so
they have tutorials for days with all
c40 base they have some After Effects
tutorials as well all the different
renderers whatever you guys use they got
it
good times ok let's um let's cut this
render here it's close enough it is
looking good enough so let's save this
as an e XR boom
and let's hop into Photoshop there it is
okay so the first thing you want to do
is content-aware fill out the render bar
because we cut it short shift backspace
on that guy done okay so I know people
does this is he'll he'll use Photoshop
to get a nice painterly look on his
images but let's let's work some of the
contrast Chris okay um let's go into
Camera Raw real quick can I not go into
Camera Raw what the heck I thought it
was control shift a how do I do this
that's because it's 32 bits probably
all right there we go so yeah let's
bring up these highlights just the bit
and the shadows can come down or maybe
they should go up I'm just trying to
work these levels here
make it make it real nice and it's funny
if you do the D haze to the opposite to
a negative number it'll kind of give it
a little bit of fog let's get the tent
let's work something green back in like
the original and then bring the vibrance
up just the hair really get those colors
going yeah that's feeling pretty good a
little blown out on the right side
that's feeling pretty sweet what I'll do
is I'll cheat and I will use let's see
let's do film film texture a Google
search for film texture and there was
one on here that was like really nice
high resolution film grain texture
and let's let's do like a search for I
think Google changed all their stuff so
if they do an advanced search any size
we want all you want like four let's try
for megapixels let's search for that
Kodak Tmax 400 yes this is what I was
looking for even art thank you sir bye
Renton thanks Trenton check out that
Kodak Tmax 400 texture this is awesome
cuz I really like this film stock it's a
black and white film stock
it's very contrast II but you know this
will give us a nice a nice look here and
we'll see how this guy up and set it to
overlay to get that film look
oh just not do that I'm gonna rasterize
this guy so that's overlay and boom you
got a film look going soo-min here and
get the details
yeah that's looking that's looking nice
um and already with octane you know they
have like a D noiser but I don't use it
because if you you know when you don't
you kind of get this grainy look and it
does kind of feel like a film texture
vibe but you see how these edges are
really sharp let's go in here and let's
like you know make it look a little more
painterly or something so if you just go
to filter and I haven't use Photoshop
filters and so long what is it there's
like a fill yeah filter we want the
filter gallery but I think we need to
switch it to 8-bit image that okay yeah
then we get to the filter gallery see
brushstrokes weird brightness on the
edges not the vibe okay so I guess right
in the middle angled strokes no cross
hatching no no no maybe this sailor kind
of rough ins up the edges looks kind of
nice and just crank the smoothness yeah
that looks that's feeling pretty good
it almost looks like it's viewed through
like some heat but I'd assume would be
really cold so that doesn't make too
much sense but it does give it a bit of
of texture to the edge and we certainly
want that so 7 and 14 are our settings
let's just see what else we can do here
sprayed strokes let's see
that's not bad either honestly it's not
it's not bad at all
yeah I'm kind of feeling that
it's pretty sweet um yeah let's that's a
whole lot of that let's see what
artistic has anything nah ooh this is
good this looks like some watercolor
even though there is a watercolor option
but it just looks horrible yeah this is
awesome it gives us the softness too you
know
sweet
yeah that looks pretty cool I don't know
between that and that and this
I think the palette knife I like the
palette knife it's nice
it kind of gives it that that hazy vibe
that the original picture has let's go
with that that looks pretty cool and the
last thing I would do is probably spend
his mountain in the back a little bit
more so we can use a what is it the
Dodge or the burn tool right burn tool
yes for the mid-tones or shadows yes all
right let's bring that down a little bit
and just kind of paint that in that's
kind of really all it needs yeah there
you go
that's basically it um I hope to do more
of this stuff with you guys I look
forward to it I know I will so I'll be
seeing you guys next week we'll figure
out a time we can do this consistently
regularly so we can all keep learning
together and I'll figure out some sort
of discord situation where we can start
putting ideas for tutorials in like a
organized place we can we can do After
Effects we can do cinema 4d we can do
texturing I really want to learn
substance designers so maybe we can do
that together but before I go go through
these comments real quick what about
Lightroom yes I love Lightroom I use it
a lot for editing photos and stuff I
mean that's obviously what it's for but
I just went through and did some photo
editing for some light painting we did
with drones and that'll be in this
week's episode of corridor crew with Ren
he does a lot of flying with one of his
like with a pilot he looks up to very
much so we went out at night at a dam
and did some like long-range long
shutter photography so that'll be
awesome what else what else
yes I'm that guy from corridor yes what
else what else yeah thanks for stopping
by guys really really appreciate it next
time I will have some music to go along
some peaceful music
sorry I'm just reading on your guys's
comments here it's difficult to talk to
just rant and read comments at the same
time but you know what I appreciate you
guys I will keep you any longer thanks
for joining the stream the very first
one and to many more I will see you guys
next time